[Musique]
oui ma part à l'automne si c'est une
somme au long du puits
cette semaine je pense que vous ignorez
pas de quelle nouvelle je veux où je
dois plutôt parlé d'un drame qui
concerne pas seulement la communauté
attikamek mais ketch et toute la
communauté des programmations les
communautés autochtones au canada et qui
devrait toucher aussi la population
québécoise et canadienne en tant que tel
on parle du décès de madame et chaque
once
je pense que cette nouvelle vient de
faire le tour du monde je pense que ce
qui est très difficile c'est que c'est
une nouvelle qui est extrêmement intime
pour beaucoup beaucoup de personnes des
communautés autochtones
je pense que c'est une situation qu'on
connaît qu'on a vécu de proches ou de
loin ça veut dire d'avoir des
difficultés à accéder aux services de
santé d'une façon culturellement et
physiquement sécuritaire pour les
membres la communauté des profanations
communauté autochtone au général ce qui
est vraiment tristement ironique c'est
que ça se produit en même temps que
l'anniversaire d un an du dépôt de la
commission va et vient du rapport avec
142 suggestions appel à l'action et je
pourrais dire une reconnaissance surtout
du racisme systémique qui
malheureusement une gangrène la relation
entre les communautés autochtones et les
différents paliers de gouvernement
depuis plus de 100 ans pour publier que
ce racisme systémique est basée dans un
système qui a été créé par la loi sur
les indiens par la constitution
canadienne karting 91 24 et depuis des
décennies la relation est compliquée
depuis de dessiner on doit transformer
cette relation entre justement le
gouvernement et les communautés
autochtones mais aussi entre la
population canadienne qui les croisent
et les populations des groupes des
différentes communautés autochtones et
c'est pour ça qu'elle souvent un mélange
entre l'idée de 1
à 6,9 systématique et un racisme
systémique
présentement le système en place donnent
l'impression qu'il ya pas de racisme
systématique mais la discrimination
existe la possibilité de vivre des
événements discriminatoire et protéger
aussi par ce système qui est mis en
place et que ce soit des hôpitaux que
soit la police que ce soit les services
administratifs
il ya cette problématique à plusieurs
niveaux et le manque de reconnaissance
aussi des gouvernements est
particulièrement présentement du
ministre monsieur legault fait que on
continue d'avoir ces problématiques en
continu d'un fusil dans toutes les
relations qui existent entre les
communautés et les services qui
devraient pouvoir accéder
je les dis souvent cette semaine il n'y
a jamais un moment dans l'histoire du
québec et du canada où la communautés
des premières nations la communauté
innue est à communauté métisse devrait
avoir toute confiance de 100% envers les
soins de santé qu'ils devraient recevoir
qu'il devrait avoir un rang qu'elle
devrait avoir confiance et on entend de
plus en plus dans les grands médias
les témoignages que nous on entend des
décennies comme quoi certaines personnes
vont même pas accéder à des soins de
santé lors de cancer l'ordre le
traitement de maladies mortelles
puisqu'ils ont déjà vécu une
discrimination ou un traitement
inadéquat
parce qu'ils étaient autochtone par le
passé donc triste anniversaire
et on parle de tristesse mais ça devrait
être une rage collectif qui existe et si
je pense que c'est ce qui va aider le
plus de changements c'est le fait que
présentement la population non
autochtone celle qui tient justement les
les rênes de ce qui peut se produire
comme changement au canada ont commencé
à écouter et à faire résonner la voix
des communautés autochtones parce
qu'elle est comme une auto directement
en parle depuis longtemps d'ailleurs
rien on attendait les témoignages de
plusieurs nations différentes
les problématiques qu'ils avaient à se
faire entendre à se faire soigner et à
se faire respecter
parce qu'ils étaient autochtone donc
triste anniversaire
comment choisir on n'est pas encore
avoir une célébration par rapport aux
changements et ce qui devrait arriver
naturellement par souci de justice au
canada ne devrait pas arriver uniquement
parce que c'est provoqué par le décès
d'une femme est présentement et bien je
pense que cette famille non seulement
doit supporter la perte d'une mère de
famille de sept enfants avec un
nouveau-né en plus mais en plus doivent
servir à supporter la cause de plusieurs
nations et la voix de plusieurs nations
par rapport à ces injustices qu'ils sont
vécus
donc je vous invite à partager cette
vidéo mais je vous invite tout
particulièrement à écouter les
communautés octobre ouvrir vos car il
aussi apporté leur voix quand des fois
ils sont trop occupés à devoir défendre
leurs vies ou défendre la justice de
base qui devrait être celle de tous
québécois ou canadiens alors je souhaite
une belle semaine et je vous invite à
écouter